j'ai toujours cultiver ma naïveté jamais
voulu développer du cynisme c'est un
monument de la pensée qui nous a quittés
aujourd'hui serge bouchard est mort à 73
ans d'un arrêt cardiaque
claude mayotte était son ami depuis plus
de 60 ans un but parfaitement raison
c'est un monument
c'est une tonne des richesses du québec
pilot vous allez vais-je pas un objectif
parce mon grand ennemi mm un bonhomme
brille avec des émissions de radio comme
de remarquables oubliés une épinette
noire nommée diesel et les chemins de
travers serge bouchard a partagé ses
réflexions pendant plus de 25 ans et
parcouru le pays d'un bout à l'autre
pour donner des conférences
non le savoir existait pas en vase clos
serge qui voulait faire c'est ouvrir à
chaque fois il disait on est capable de
l'expliquer simplement diplômés des
universités laval et meaghan serge
bouchard avait étudié le savoir des
chasseurs innus du labrador et la
culture des camionneurs du nord du
canada
c'est les artistes de la l'embrayage
j'ai un mot en tête c'est bienveillance
vraiment la bienveillance à l'égard des
communautés des communautés autochtones
les camionneurs de tous les collègues
qui le côtoyez chaque personne en valait
la peine pour pour singe les réactions à
son décès ont été nombreuses
toute la classe politique a souligné le
départ d'un grand sage québec par
quelqu'un qui analyse et notre société
sous toutes ses coutures au cours des
dernières années qui était un excellent
total au cours de sa carrière il publie
plus d'une vingtaine de livres emportant
plusieurs distinctions dont le titre
d'officier de l'ordre national du québec
serge bouchard avait perdu sa deuxième
femme et collaboratrice marie christine
lévesque à la fin l'an dernier d'une
tumeur au cerveau lui avait d'ailleurs
consacré le livre un café avec marie ce
très très dur de faire des deuils de
s'asseoir attentes pandémie c'est dix
fois pire aujourd'hui le québec pleure
la disparition d'un grand penseur et
vulgarisateur qui a su partager son
amour de la connaissance et je les perds
du souhait perdu physiquement
il sera toujours là parce que s'y
livrent les à côté de moi plus jolie des
passages des fois et tellement brillé
que ce qu'écrivait mais un temps durs
qui cruel c'est que c'est le temps de
l'univers c'est le temps universel 10
passes
il est irréversible li na aucun sens
c'est bien mon outil ici n'est bien
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]